[MUSIC PLAYING]
I grew up in Lyubertsy, a small town near Moscow.
A small town, it borders Moscow.
And the first few years,
I'd go to school in my town,
and for the last two years, I'd
go to math school in Moscow.
Actually, I wasn't really interested in math,
I was more into history and literature,
but parents nudged me toward math
because they knew that for Jewish children,
it was nearly impossible to get into a university
pursuing a History of Literature degree.
And the only way to higher education
was a technical degree.
That's why I went to math school and then enrolled
in the Applied Mathematics program at an institute,
got a technical degree, but the interest
in Humanities somehow took over.
And first I got interested in the Philosophy
of Science, then History of Science,
I wrote a dissertation on the history
of AI research in the United States.
While I was living in Russia, I was
an expert in American science.
But then I enrolled for a doctoral degree
at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology
majoring in History and Social Studies of Science and Technology
and came here already having one degree from Russia
— a scientific degree of a candidate of philosophical sciences.
And then here, I wrote another dissertation,
now as a historian of Russian science —
a dissertation on the history of Soviet cybernetics.
Ironically, the object of my study was always
on the other side of the Atlantic from me.
And after that, this dissertation was published as a book
From Newspeak to Cyberspeak: A History of Soviet Cybernetics.
And then... it's typical for historians of science
to change their field of interest every few years.
That's why when I finished my project on the history of Soviet
cybernetics, I took up the history of the Soviet space program.
And I spent many years working on this topic.
But the last few years, life has
lead to my return to mathematics
and now I work in the math department at MIT.
And I live and work among mathematicians, so to speak.
And my current research project is based
on oral interviews with mathematicians.
I have already interviewed more than 90 mathematicians
on the topic Social History of Soviet Mathematics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I must say that I was not
a particularly athletic child.
I liked to read books, so I
enjoyed reading science fiction
and thus joined in on the cosmic dreams.
Although I collected space-themed stamps, so I guess
I already had some kind of attraction to space.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Interest in the space program initially stemmed from
my interest in cybernetics and computing machinery,
because I approached this topic from
the side of using onboard computers
in the US Apollo space program.
As you know, the Apollo lunar landing was possible
thanks to the use of an onboard computer —
the first computer
on integrated circuits.
And it was the history of the Appolo
onboard computer that I worked on.
And interviewed veterans of
the American space program.
And then I became interested: what was
happening at this time in the Soviet Union,
where, as you know, they also had a lunar
program (though secret), were computers used there?
I became interested,
and I started to dig into this topic,
work in archives, interview veterans
of the Soviet space program.
And gradually this topic began to go
beyond just using computers,
because it turned out that the Soviet Union was 20 years
behind in the field of onboard computers for spacecraft.
And in this sense, I became interested:
how did they fly without such advanced technology?
And then I wondered how Soviet
spacecraft were generally designed,
what share of the functions was transferred
to automation, to some machines,
and what share of the functions remained with
the cosmonaut and was given to manual control.
It turned out that this is not a
simple technical question.
This is a question that was open for
debate between engineers and cosmonauts,
leaders of the Soviet space program.
That is, to some extent, it reflected
not so much technical efficiency but
rather the political weight that these groups
that participated in the negotiations had.
Then the whole thing was starting to unravel,
and I wrote a book on the history of the
Soviet space program called Soviet Space Myths,
where the issue of computers and automation
is only one particular side of this big topic,
which covers the interaction of various
groups within the Soviet space program:
how they defined Soviet space policy,
how they interacted with the wider public.
So sort of a sociocultural history
of the Soviet space program.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, we all know about Sputnik —
at least we know this word.
Launched October 1957 in the Soviet Union, Sputnik was
the first artificial body launched around the Earth.
And it was launched on a rocket, which was
a modified intercontinental ballistic missile.
In fact, the space program was an offshoot
of the military nuclear strike program,
where these intercontinental ballistic missiles
were created in order to carry a nuclear payload
and fly from the Soviet Union to America.
Really, this was the main goal of this program.
And, after Sergei Korolev, the chief
designer of these missiles,
managed to successfully test his
rocket — the famous "seven", R-7,
there were still a few copies
of the missiles made for tests,
and he asked for permission from the political leadership
of the Soviet Union to use them for space flights.
It was a roots initiative.
And the launch of Sputnik
thus began the space race.
The Americans were catching up, and the
Soviet engineers launched first each time,
had what you would call cosmic triumphs.
After the first Sputnik was the
launch of the first cosmonaut,
then the launch of a cosmonaut
who orbited for an entire day,
then there was the launch of two spacecraft,
which were simultaneously in orbit,
then there was the launch of a
spacecraft with three cosmonauts,
the launch of a spaceship with a woman
on board and, finally, a spacewalk.
All these are the famous Soviet space triumphs, which
were achieved in a short period — from 1961 to 1965.
And all the while, the Soviet Union was giving the
impression that it was in the lead in this race.
And, indeed, these achievements were the first.
But at the same time, a more ambitious goal
was being worked on in the United States —
landing and delivery of astronauts to the
surface of the Moon, their return to Earth.
It was also a political task — to rehabilitate for the
defeat with Sputnik and the first cosmonaut Gagarin.
And a lot of money has been invested in it.
And, while the Soviet leaders of the space program
paid more attention to these space triumphs,
leaders of the American program worked on
improving technology, on the Gemini program
and then on the Apollo program, which led to the success
of the lunar space program in the United States.
But the Soviet Union, having learned about
this, began to develop its own lunar program.
Prior to this, the Soviet Union
focused on a flight to Mars,
but now, since there is a lunar race,
they have refocused on the Moon.
But then there is a very interesting story — how the competition arose within the Soviet space program
which led to splitting the efforts of the Soviet Union in this lunar program,
when two parallel programs were funded:
one to fly around the Moon and return to Earth,
and the other — for the flight and landing — the
cosmonaut's walk on the Moon and return to Earth.
It seems that these are very close programs,
but they were separated in the Soviet Union.
They were developing... two completely different
rockets were made for this, different spacecraft,
different groups of cosmonauts
were preparing for this.
So the Soviet Union directed
efforts in two directions at once,
and in the end, there were not enough resources
to sufficiently develop the technology,
and the Americans were the first to go to the Moon.
It would seem that that's it, it's the
final victory of American astronautics.
But the spirit of victory quickly
disappears, something new must be done,
and both countries found themselves in a situation where they had
to somehow show something, some new achievements after the Moon.
And at that moment, the Soviet Union refocused
on the creation of orbital stations,
and said: although the Americans send
people to the Moon, no one needs it,
but we will launch an orbital station, and
we will conduct scientific research there.
And at the same time, the joint
Apollo-Soyuz project was launched,
where in 1975 two ships, an American
and a Soviet one, docked in orbit.
It was also a very interesting symbolic act, and a technologically complex one,
when they had to work out the docking of
two completely different technical devices.
And such a docking that would
be symbolically equivalent,
so that there are no active and passive ships,
as docking of spaceships was done before.
Therefore, it was necessary to invent a new docking device,
which maintained the technological equality of the parties.
So the politics was woven into technological
design at precisely this micro level.
After that, a new race began — with the shuttle.
A shuttle was launched in America, and the
Soviet Union started to develop a shuttle too.
Few people know about this, but the
Soviet Union built its own shuttle
that carried out a test flight in a completely
automatic mode, without cosmonauts on board —
it launched, went into orbit and then returned and
landed completely autonomously, without cosmonauts.
It was actually a technological breakthrough,
which was completely forgotten after that
because this program was closed.
And the Soviet Union returned to
launching old and already tested Soyuz
spacecraft to orbital stations.
And then — a new round of cooperation.
We see here that periods of competition
and periods of cooperation are alternating.
And now a new period of cooperation —
the International Space Station
which is still functioning and to a large extent supports
the two large space programs in the two countries,
provides a political purpose for the
existence of this project.
And here we see — Soyuz fly there, and commercial
ships are already starting to fly from America.
So new breakthrough technologies are
being built into the old canvas,
but those that will probably outgrow it, since
this is the development of commercial technologies,
perhaps it will surpass this narrow function of delivering
cosmonauts and astronauts to the International Space Station
and will find a wider field of applications.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I am most familiar with
the Apollo-Soyuz program,
because it was actually
the first cooperation program.
And it was very difficult for two programs — to open up
and start talking with specialists from the other side,
because they were used to treating their work as
something super secret that needs to be concealed.
And now they had to find a common language,
somehow make themselves cooperate.
And it turned out that it's
actually not such a difficult thing,
that specialists from both sides understand
each other very well, easily find a common language
and they are very interested
in working with each other.
And teams of specialists from the States started coming to the Soviet Union,
and from the Union to the States, and working very successfully.
And it turned out that the addition of these efforts
greatly enriches both programs from the technical side.
And after this experience of cooperation,
the people who took part in this
became great enthusiasts of
further cooperation projects.
And it seems to me that this cooperation
has a broader political meaning,
because the more Russia and America cooperate,
the more people on both sides see the benefit
and express their support for further cooperation,
which proves to be mutually beneficial.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Knowledge of the Russian language is absolutely
necessary for the history of cosmonautics, of course,
because archival documents are in Russian.
If you want to interview
someone, then, as a rule, veterans
of the Soviet space program
do not know foreign languages,
grew up in the Soviet Union where teaching
foreign languages was not well established
and they didn't have much
opportunity to practice either.
And it is very important to know the language well, for example,
in order to work with audio materials. In the space archive in Moscow
I listened to recordings of the cosmonauts'
conversations with Earth, with the Mission Control Center.
This is, in general, an underexplored part
of the materials, and a very interesting one,
because some issues of equipment
failures also pop up there
as well as some kind of negotiations on the approval of certain
actions that the cosmonauts requested, and Earth gave them.
This is where this social aspect of the relationship
between cosmonauts and engineers on Earth comes to light.
And to understand all the subtleties of these negotiations,
a good knowledge of the Russian language is absolutely necessary.
Well, in general, for interviewing, in order
for people to open up, to believe you,
to tell you something that
they might not tell someone else,
it is very important to establish a trusting relationship with them,
and a good command of the language is essential for this.
This lets you win their trust
and allows you to get close enough
so that this conversation becomes interesting and
touches on topics that go beyond a purely formal interview.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It seems to me that cooperation
between Russian and American,
European, Chinese,
Indian space programs —
is absolutely inevitable in the future.
Even if now there is competition somewhere,
there will be cooperation later.
Historical experience shows
that this always happens.
And in this sense, knowledge of the Russian language will be critical,
and you will gain a great advantage thanks to this knowledge,
because you will be the person with the expertise
needed to participate in this collaboration.
And the Russian space program has accumulated
a lot of experience, very interesting technologies
that will be interesting in this cooperation,
and knowledge of the Russian language will
allow you to participate in such joint programs
and, of course, it will be useful to anyone
who works in the space industry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Over the past few years, new
things that have happened —
of course, it is the launch
of commercial manned spacecraft,
launch into orbit and suborbital flights of three
commercial spacecraft have already taken place.
This marks a certain transition of
cosmonautics from a purely state business,
financed by state governments,
to wide commercial use
which, as a rule, is much more efficient, breeds more
innovations and develops much faster and more interestingly.
Very often, the government first invests
in the development of some technology,
and then business picks it up and
develops it and makes it for everyday use.
Let's take computers: the first computers were financed
by the government for some kind of military calculations,
and as soon as business began to use computers,
the range of their application immediately expanded,
and now we have these computers and the like
not only on our desks but also in our hands.
Space technology is also evolving from
purely propagandist and military applications
to communications, to applications for some
kind of global signal exchange, for the Internet,
and now for space tourism.
And who knows what other applications
business will come up with that we all need?
Therefore, it seems to me, from the viewpoint of
expanding the capabilities of manned cosmonautics
new commercial spacecraft
play a key role here.
But I also think it is very important
to develop automatic stations,
and in particular the rovers that
are now exploring the surface of Mars
because this year already, two new
rovers — a Chinese and an American one —
landed on the surface of Mars, and they create
a completely different impression of space for us
by broadcasting these pictures in good resolution,
through which we now perceive the
space as something no longer alien,
but as something that fits
into our perception of the world.
And, of course, automatic devices
have much greater capabilities
and allow for a wider range of scientific
observations than a person in space
who is limited in their capacity.
Most of the equipment of manned spacecraft
is spent on maintaining human life.
Very few resources are
left for actual research.
Therefore, from the viewpoint of scientific research
and expansion of our space knowledge in general,
the use of automatic spacecraft — it
seems the main path of development to me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The project is called The Challenge.
It seems to me that this is a very interesting turn in
the relationship between cosmonautics and popular culture.
If earlier mass culture
followed cosmonautics,
that is, some images and symbols of
cosmonautics circulated in popular culture,
so, cosmonautics developed
for its own purposes,
and mass culture perceived,
processed, distributed, reimagined it,
then now, mass culture, in a sense,
starts to use cosmonautics
to achieve its own goals,
when they are able to
buy a flight to a space station,
and it is a space station that is
being used as a movie set.
And in this sense, cosmonautics is already becoming a somewhat
service industry for the mass media industry, mass culture.
It seems to me that this changes the relationship
between these two sociocultural phenomena
and generally shows the ever-increasing
role of mass media in our lives,
when they subdue even such powerful
technological projects as space ones.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the field of cosmonautics, I would
name 'Mars rover' the word of the year.
It seems to me that it is these new automatic vehicles
roaming the expanses of Mars and bringing Mars to us,
allowing us to be there, as it were —
this is a new concept that enters our lives.
If before, there was a lunar rover, which was
a propaganda project of the Soviet government,
diverting attention from
the loss of the lunar race,
then now, the Mars rover is actually
a triumph for all mankind,
when both American and Chinese machines
are now roaming the expanses of Mars.
For us, 'Mars rover' is a word that, it seems to me,
is already becoming a household name in a way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Books.
This is a difficult question. Probably two books:
The Master and Margarita by Bulgakov and The Gift by Nabokov.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Probably, it is the physicist Landau who was not
only a brilliant physicist, but also a great wit.
It was he who said that the sciences are
divided into natural, unnatural (humanities)
and against nature
(such as Marxism and Leninism).
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Try to come up with something new.
Learn. And don't be afraid to make mistakes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To Mars.